[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec voir
yann mancini bonjour marion est notre
invité cette semaine et or en verger
bonjour bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes député la république en
marge des yvelines et vous êtes
également porte parole du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale et nous allons
refaire ensemble la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec edouard philippe qui
a présenté mercredi les grandes lignes
de la réforme des institutions
l'exécutif souhaite passer par le
parlement pour adopter cette réforme
mais la partie est loin d'être gagnée
tant les mesures passent mal au sénat et
puis là loisirs et immigration est
arrivé en débat en commission à
l'assemblée nationale elle crée des
remous au sein même de la majorité
une partie des députés de la république
en marche la juge déséquilibrée et
demandent plus d'humanité
mais gérard collomb affiche sa fermeté
le premier ministre dont philippe a donc
dévoilé mercredi à sa réforme de la
constitution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'introduction de la proportionnelle
réduction du nombre de députés ou encore
limitation à trois mandats
après plusieurs semaines de concertation
adore philippaerts a détaillé à la
réforme des institutions est les détails
avec l nelson gaestel après des semaines
de tractations le premier ministre a mis
fin au suspense
edouard philippe a dévoilé les grandes
lignes de la réforme des institutions
voulue par emmanuel macron parmi ces
mesures c'est sûrement celle qui
concerne le parlement qui feront le plus
débat
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république les projets
de loi organique et ordinaire prévoient
quant à eux une réduction de 30% du
nombre de députés de sénateurs dans des
conditions qui garantissent la
représentation de tous les départements
et territoires
l'introduction d'une dose de
représentation proportionnelle aux
élections législatives pour 15% des
sièges de députés à pourvoir
enfin l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats dans le temps
au delà de trois mandats identique
complet et consécutif pour les
parlementaires les présidents
d'exécutifs locaux à l'exception des
maires des communes de moins de 9000
habitants
l'encadrement du droit d'amendement qui
avait fait l'unanimité contre lui au
sein de l'opposition a quant à lui était
abandonné même s'il sera limitée
concernant la réforme de la constitution
le premier ministre a annoncé la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république et la réforme du conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
deviendra une chambre de la société
civile chargé de consulter les citoyens
sur des projets d'avenir
par ailleurs conformément à ce qu
emmanuel macron avait annoncé lors de sa
visite en corse
le gouvernement souhaite inscrire la
corse dans la loi fondamentale
l'ensemble de ces projets sera présenté
en conseil des ministres le 9 mai avec
pour objectif une première lecture avant
l'été or verger cette réforme était
voulue comme une grande réforme est ce
que finalement la montagne a accouché
d'une souris
non je pense que c'est pas une souris
d'arriver à avoir un rééquilibrage des
pouvoirs parce que ça n'a pas été dit
mais moi je suis très attaché c'est la
capacité pour le parlement d'avoir des
outils d'évaluation propre survenue mais
nos moyens
lui à sion et de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement il faut qu'on ait des
outils propres
ce sera le cas et puis c'est pas non
plus une souris pour reprendre votre
expression d' introduire la
proportionnelle de limiter le nombre de
mandats dans le temps
je pense que ce sont des réformes qui
sont attendues par les français outre le
fait qu'elles ont été annoncé pendant la
campagne présidentielle
puis par présent la république quoi nous
avait réunis en congrès à versailles ce
sont des réformes qui sont à penser que
taiwan pour la durée l'essentiel n'ont
pas d'autres priorités
il ya toujours d'autres priorités mais
je pense que le mouvement de
renouvellement
on a réussi à insuffler lors de
l'élection présidentielle puis des
élections législatives
ça doit pas être juste une fois ça doit
pas être juste ce mandat là il faut que
ça puisse inscrire dans le temps et pour
que ça s'inscrive dans le temps il faut
un moment changer les règles de
fonctionnement y compris notre
constitution notamment sur la question
de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
la question de la proportionnelle et la
question du non-cumul mais en quoi les
français seront mieux représentés
finalement s'il ya moins de députés de
sénateurs c'est moins de députés et de
sénateurs mais c'est aussi mieux de
parlementaires parce que l'idée de faire
cette réforme c'est de la faire à moyens
constants
ça coûtera pas un euro aux français mais
ça permettra aux parlementaires de mieux
faire leur travail
on l'a souvent dit nous depuis qu'on est
arrivé parce que on découvre aussi de
l'intérieur le mode de fonctionnement de
cette institution et on voit la
faiblesse aussi du sénat et de
l'assemblée par rapport justement au
gouvernement à l'exécutif
parce que nous n'avons pas des moyens
propres pour pouvoir expertise et
évaluer ce sera le garantis justement
sur ces moyens elles n'ont pas été
abordés par ed orfi alors il ya
plusieurs choses par exemple le fait que
la cour des comptes puissent être
rattachés beaucoup plus aujourd'hui au
parlement alors qu'aujourd'hui elle
conseille autant l'exécutif que le
parlement le fait qu'on est un outil
propre d'évaluation qui soient dédiés à
l'assemblée nationale on pense par
exemple à frans stratégie qui est un
outil qui existe déjà
donc c'est toujours à zéro euro
supplémentaire pour les français mais
nous ça va changer la manière avec
laquelle on va pouvoir travailler et
puis aussi des parlementaires qui auront
plus de moyens pas pour eux mêmes et
pour leur équipe parlementaire qui
feront qu'on aura aussi un contact avec
la population avec les élus l'eau
ou qui sera d'autant renforcée alors
pour adopter cette réforme par voie
parlementaire l'exécutif va avoir besoin
du sénat mais les mesures annoncées
passe mal au sein de la haute assemblée
jérôme ravi les annonces faites place
maintenant au débat au parlement le
gouvernement pourra évidemment compter
sur le groupe
lrm et ses 21 sénateurs pour appuyer sa
réforme
le groupe des indépendants et celui du
rds ce malgré la diversité de leurs
compositions devrait également soutenir
le projet même si le respect des
territoires ruraux sera attentivement
défendu crois qu'il n'y a pas de
surprise c'est ce qui était annoncé sur
les engagements du du président de la
république largement approuvée par les
français n'ont pas au printemps dernier
mais qui sont encore à prouver
aujourd'hui le groupe centriste et ses
cinquante sénateurs devra encore être
convaincus
ils réclamaient davantage de
proportionnelle et plaide pour une
baisse de 25% du nombre de
parlementaires mais le président du
groupe espère tout de même un accord
c'est une base importante qui permet de
converger parce que on n'est pas loin me
semble-t-il d'un objectif si tout le
monde y met du sien côté socialiste des
doutes importants subsistent si la
partie constitutionnel ne devrait pas
poser problème
la préservation des prérogatives du
parlement sera centrale dans leur
positionnement
il était important de remettre plus tôt
le parlement au centre des du dispositif
ce n'est pas exactement ce que je lis de
la volonté qui est affiché les
communistes s'opposeront eux à la
réforme dénonçant presque tous ses
aspects
mais c'est vers le groupe l'est
républicain que se tournent tous les
regards le président du sénat gérard
larcher a été au coeur des négociations
avec l'exécutif et a réussi à imposer
certaines lignes rouges comme la
présence d'au moins un sénateurs et
députés par département
il est pourtant signataire d'un
communiqué du parti les républicains qui
affirment que ce projet ne peut être
accepté par le parti
ce qui augure de discussions animées
lors des débats parlementaires à venir
gérard larcher qui a donné une interview
ce vendredi au figaro il estime qu'il va
encore y avoir du travail parlementaire
sur cette réforme
y at il encore des marges de manoeuvre
des négociations possibles évidemment
c'est le même le principe du débat
parlementaire
on va pouvoir discuter des différentes
dispositions pas uniquement celles qui
ont été aussi les plus commentés parce
que probablement les plus attendus par
l'opinion mais aussi nous tout le
processus législatif la manière avec
laquelle on articule le travail entre
l'assemblée et le sénat gérard larcher
il pense par exemple à la réduction de
30% du nombre de parlementaires
vous êtes étudiant total désaccord c'est
un peu paradoxal parce que pendant la
campagne présidentielle les républicains
avait un candidat qui s'appelait
françois fillon et françois fillon dans
son programme
vous voulez qu'on est 400 députés donc
c'est 30% de baisse et 200 sénateurs
nous classe était même 40% de baisse du
nombre de sénateurs gérard chef et le
président de son comité de soutien
donc je pense que vous avez vous déjà
une posture politicienne de la part du
président du sénat je pense que de la
part des républicains en général et de
laurent wauquiez en particulier oui il y
à une posture je pense qu'on a réussi à
travailler avec gérard larcher le
président de la république françois de
rugy edouard philippe
justement pour avancer parce que vous
avez vu qu'il ya eu quand même justement
des évolutions entre le texte
initialement proposé le texte qui a été
présenté hier par le prêt ni ça veut
dire que les concertations existe que le
dialogue existe et maintenant place en
effet au débat par le vent rescousse le
chiffre de 30% il peut changer
bah écoutez nous on s'était engagé
pendant la campagne et une réduction
d'un tiers donc on est conforme à nos
engagements en parlant de 30% de
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
moi je sais que mon groupe parlementaire
y est très attaché je peux pas préjuger
de ce qui ressortira des débats mais je
pense que c'était nécessaire qu'on
arrive à se dire qu'il faut encore une
fois réduire le nombre de parlementaires
et moi j'aimais une condition c'est bien
que ce soit fait à moyens constants pour
qu'on ait vraiment les moyens de
travailler efficacement aux vues à la
revue juste vu de la position de gérard
larcher est ce que vous pensez qu'un
accord avec le sénat est encore possible
moi je pense que c'est possible et puis
je pense que c'est souhaitable parce que
le sénat s'est beaucoup modernisé aussi
ces dernières années aussi sous
l'impulsion de gérard larcher d'ailleurs
et je pense que le sénat au regard
aujourd'hui de l'opinion des français de
leur volonté de modernisation de la vie
politique a aussi tout à gagner à
accompagner cette réforme alors
l'assemblée également cette réforme de
la
constitution mécontente l'opposition
écoutez ces quelques réactions sont des
miettes on ne représente pas autant de
millions d'électeurs qui ne seront pas
représentés à l'assemblée nationale avec
15% de proportionnelle le compte n'y est
pas nous avons expliqué que l' équilibre
à nos yeux était de 20 % 20 % ça permet
de dégager des majorités et de garantir
la représentation des courants d'idées
parce que les républicains vont voter la
révision constitutionnelle si votre pas
la révision constitutionnelle
ça nous permettra de réouvrir le champ
de la discussion parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale pascal
proportionnelle c'est une loi simple
donc le taux de 15%
on peut le monte attention à ce que tous
les territoires puissent être
correctement représentés notamment avec
des distances qui va être très
importante le jour vous aurez un député
dans un territoire très rurale avec
beaucoup de kilomètres carrés et de
route à parcourir
ça sera plus la même relation que qui
n'existera que celle qui peut exister
aujourd'hui c'est un changement c'est un
vrai changement il ya pour nous un coup
de force qui est fait contre la
démocratie et la capacité d'intervention
populaire dans le pays en renforçant
encore le pouvoir exécutif le pouvoir du
président de la république
donc pour nous il ya un danger grave là
qui est en train de se présenter nous
allons le combattre
demandons un référendum sur ce sujet
or berger vous avez entendu à les
réactions du modem vous les avez déçu
vos alliés avec ses 15 % de
proportionnelle c'était pourtant à une
des conditions du ralliement de françois
bayrou à emmanuel macron vous craignez
sa riposte aujourd'hui moi je grimpais
la riposte tout simplement parce que le
modem est au coeur de la majorité
présidentielle et parlementaire issia
l'assemblée nationale on travaille
ensemble et main dans la main la
majorité s'est pas uniquement la
république en marche impliquant marche
et le modèle émergent tueur bayrou dit
aujourd'hui que cette réforme c'est un
point de départ et non un point
d'arrivée
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est un
point de départ puisque le débat
parlementaire n'a pas encore eu lieu
et donc on a des possibilités
d'améliorer encore un certain nombre de
choses mais sur la proportion
l'engagement quel était-il d'intégrer
une dose de proportionnelle on ne
s'était pas engagé à dire on intégrera
20 25 30 % de proportionnelle une dose
de proportionnelle pour quoi pour venir
corriger ce qui aujourd'hui nous semble
être un handicap dans notre
représentativité à l'assemblée nationale
parce qu'on le sait on a aujourd'hui
des partis qui sont sous représentés par
rapport au poids qu'ils pèsent assez
suffisant pour une meilleure
représentativité ou est-ce du
saupoudrage
c'est une correction c'est l'objectif
moi j'ai jamais été en faveur de la
proportionnelle intégrale ou d'une
proportionnelle qui ferait que demain on
aurait du mal à avoir à dégager des
majorités et quand on voit la situation
qui est celle de l'italie la situation
qui est celle de l'allemagne ça peut
quand même légitimement nous interroger
sur le risque couru
si demain on ne garantit pas un mode de
scrutin qui permettent de dégager des
majorités mais du coup vous nous dites
une dose une dose a été promis mais
pâtit ça veut dire que ce chiffre de 15%
il peut évoluer
moi je peux encore une fois je vais pas
préjuger des débats parlementaires
moi je voudrais qu'on arrive à obtenir
un chiffre qui garantissent qui
garantissent qu'on puisse dégager des
majorités et avec la réduction du nombre
de parlementaires
évidemment il ya les deux sont liés
quand vous réduisez le nourrir selon
vous du coup moi je pense que je suive
de 15% et un chef qui est équilibrée
parce que ça permet de garantir des
majorités tout en ayant un correctif sur
la représentativité des partis
politiques et c'était ça l'enjeu au vu
des oppositions on vient de l'entente à
la fois sénat à l'assemblée alors
référendum est inévitable alors de toute
façon avant de convoquer le référendum
il faut qu'il y ait un débat
parlementaire et surtout il faut qu'il y
ait un vote dans les mêmes termes à
l'assemblée et au sénat sur le texte
donc on peut pas se passer du débat
parlementaire on ne peut pas faire sans
le sénat on est obligé condamné à
réussir ensemble cette réforme
de toute façon on aura ce débat j'espère
vraiment qu'il sera fructueux dans la
qualité des échanges qu'on pourra avoir
aussi loin des postures des uns et des
autres et après c'est le président de la
république qui décidera
à l'issue de ce n'est pas risqué
politiquement pour vous de devoir passer
par un référendum
c'est toujours un risque quand vous
convoquer un référendum de savoir si les
gens se prononceront sur la question qui
leur est posée ou pas là en plus sûr est
peut-être une multitude de questions à
poser
quand on voit la densité aussi de la
réforme qui est présenté et puis elle
certaines mesures qui sont peut-être
certainement les plus emblématiques pour
les français mais qui ne sont pas une
loi constitutionnelle
par exemple la proportionnelle c'est en
effet une loi simple donc un vote à la
sent
les au sénat et en l'occurrence ici
suffisant donc voyez je pense qu'il faut
être un peu prudent d'abord il faut
qu'on n'était pas parlementaire est en
tout cas je pense qu'il est très attendu
on va passer à un autre l'autre texte de
la semaine ont leurs vergers puisque à
l'assemblée la commission des loi
examiné le projet de loi asile et
immigration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et comme prévu l'examen de ce texte a
suscité des débats au sein même de la
majorité à l'exemple de l'article 6 il
prévoit de passer le délai de recours
des déboutés dans mois à quinze jours
une dizaine de députés de la république
en marche s'y oppose l avant dans gaza
les députés communistes ceux de la
france en soumises ou encore les
socialistes du groupe nouvelle gauche
unanime contre l'article 6 qui fait
passer de un mois à quinze jours le
délai de recours
une opposition logique mais cette mesure
cristallise aussi les critiques dans la
majorité
chez les élus du modem et même au sein
du groupe la république en marche
certains députés n'ont pas hésité à
prendre la parole pour dénoncer cette
disposition
quand on veut aller vite et quand on
veut néanmoins garder l'équilibré en
sont toujours et encore aux personnes
les plus vulnérables n'avoir que 15
jours pour faire un recours
je continue et j'insiste en disant que
c'est un délai beaucoup trop beaucoup
trop court je crois qu'on n'est pas dans
l'amélioration du droit on va dans le
moins de droits pour les dernières
agressions et donc c'est pour ça que je
pense que ce c'est ce ce délai cette
réduction des délais est inacceptable
ils sont une trentaine à avoir signé un
amendement pour rester au délai d'un
mois
amendement rejeté la rapporteur est le
responsable du texte pour le groupe ont
proposé d'inscrire dans la loi la
possibilité de déposer un recours
sommaire avant de compléter son dossier
présenté comme une contrepartie à la
réduction du délai de recours
cette proposition suscite l'ironie de
l'opposition de droite
on assiste on l'a bien compris a dépeint
d'entre elles est socialiste de la
majorité en marche elle qui est elle
sans doute ancrée différemment sur la
scène politique bon j'ai le sentiment
que l'amendement de la rapporteure un
amendement en même temps devant les
critiques de certains députés en marche
l'amendement n'a pas été adopté il reste
à la commission des lois plus de 20
articles à examiner par mieux
l'article 16
très controversée sur l'augmentation de
la durée maximale de rétention
aurore bergé l'examen dû texte le
confirmer il ya bien des dissensions au
sein de la majorité certains à députés
de votre groupe la république en marche
pourrait ne pas voter ce texte vous le
regrettez vous pour l'instant moi je
sais pas c'est des parlementaires qui ne
voterons pas ce texte on en est au stade
des débats en commission où les
parlementaires sont libres de déposer
des amendements certains l'ont fait les
ont défendu l' île on part pour certains
été rejetée pour d'autres ils ont été
adoptés ça la vie parlementaire et le
débat parlementaire que l'on doit avoir
de manière sereine moi je suis pas là
pour faire les comptes et savoir si
untel ou unetelle ne votera pas le texte
elle consomme la belle manière de la
même manière moi je ne suis pas dans la
recherche à tout prix l'unanimité moi je
crois que ce texte il est essentiel je
crois qu'on a besoin de réduire les
délais d'instruction du droit d'asile
je pense qu'on a besoin de réaffirmer ce
qu'est le droit d'asile et de le
préserver et je pense qu'on a besoin
aussi de dire aux français qu'on envoie
un message de fermeté clair pour que
ceux qui sont déboutés le soin de
manière effective c'est ça le coeur du
projet de loi et donc moi je veux pas
dénaturer le projet de loi pour une
recherche à tout prix de l'unanimité
mais c'est symbolique c'est un texte
important pour le gouvernement est ce
que des voix de votre groupe manqueront
au gouvernement sur ce texte
mais je ne l'espère pas mais je ne le
sait pas parce qu'on n'a pas encore fini
les débats parlementaires mais vous ne
les vois que j'ai assisté à certains à
certains débats en commission des lois
même si j'en suis pas membre
et c'est vrai qu'il y avait une très
forte affluence parce que c'est un texte
qu est un texte qui touche aussi à
l'essentiel et ce qui est en effet
important pour la majorité pour le
gouvernement ce que je sais c'est que ce
texte sera voté et qu'il aura une très
large majorité pour être voté c'est un
texte répressif il faut mieux expulser -
accueillir c'est la philosophie de ce
texte dit pas qu'il faut - accueillir on
dit qu'il faut mieux accueillir et c'est
ça la difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui
et là pour le coup on a un consensus qui
est très large parlementaire politiques
associatives pour dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'accueil n'est pas digne dans notre
pays on accueille mal et on n'intègre
pas donc l'objectif c'est déjà ça veut
dire que sur le droit d'asile c'est à
dire celles et ceux qui sont vraiment en
situation de vulnérabilité
il faut continuer à les accuser mais
vous entendez ces demandes de plus
d'humanité mais là plus d'humanité c'est
ce qu'on fait dans ce texte
qui peut considérer que c'est plus
humain de faire attendre au moins une 14
mois en demandeur d'asile plutôt que
demain six mois vous pouvez même émergé
dans ce tacle et on a même introduit des
choses dans ce texte par exemple le fait
que pour les personnes qui pourraient
demain subir des persécutions en raison
de leur homosexualité de leur
orientation sexuelle
elle ne pourrait pas être renvoyés dans
un pays et qui pratique malheureusement
qui a des pratiques qui sont violents
dangereuse envers ces personnes ça c'est
une proposition de la rapporteure
soutenu par le gouvernement donc on a
encore enrichi ce texte
on a aussi permis par exemple que pour
les mineurs isolés ils puissent être
rejoints par leurs frères et leur soeur
donc on a vraiment améliorer encore ce
texte majorité et gouvernement
un mot sur gérard collomb puisque c'est
lui qui porte le texte mardi lors d'une
audition à l'assemblée il a martelé
qu'il ne changerait pas sur l'essentiel
du texte est ce que c'était la bonne
attitude avant mais il présente un texte
auquel il croit et vous ne ferez pas
défendre à gérard collomb un texte
auquel ils ne croient pas donc ils
croient à ce texte
il croit à son équilibre moi j'en suis
convaincu et la majorité en est
convaincu donc je crois qu'il a raison
de garantir l'équilibré qui est déjà
porté dans ce texte
allez passons à présent à l'actualité
politique avec un autre partenaire du
figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et jim scherr à ses bons jours vous nous
avez rejoint pour faire le tour
justement de cette actualité politique
et sociale bonjour or berger a en effet
parlé l'actualité sociale avec la grogne
des cheminots qui a pris de l'ampleur
cette semaine on a vu le gouvernement
assez présent dans l'est dans les médias
est ce qu'il ya eu un changement de ton
peut-être plus de pédagogie à mesure que
la grogne s'amplifie
je pense qu'on a besoin de continuer à
expliquer pourquoi on mène cette réforme
serait fort mal tombe pas du ciel ça
fait des années ce n'est des dizaines
d'années qu'un certain nombre de
gouvernements souhaitaient la conduire
soit il ya renoncé soit reculée donc ça
veut dire qu'elle est importante mais
qu'elle n'est pas facile à conduire
donc ça nécessite qu'on continue à
expliquer à la fois ce qu'est
l'ouverture à la concurrence parce que
quoi qu'il arrive cette ouverture alors
la concurrence aura lieu et pourquoi on
doit mieux armer la sncf dans cette
ouverture à la concurrence du plus
d'empathie peut-être plus de respect
vis-à-vis des cheminots est ce que ça ça
a été un changement de ton oui j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on ait été irrespectueux
vis-à-vis castleton que l'exécutif
compte et qui le fait que la réforme
allait passer naturellement que le
statut des cheminots étaient pas
vraiment respectée dans l'opinion et
puis en fait on se rend compte que
finalement il ya un mouvement qui
s'installe
je pense pas que les français soient en
défense d'un statut pour tel ou tel
d'ailleurs catégories de population par
contre il est en attente de savoir
qu'est ce qui va changer dans leur
quotidien pourquoi demain une ouverture
à la concurrence et les investissements
qu'on va faire 36 milliards
d'investissements quand même en faveur
de la sncf ça va permettre d'avoir des
trains qui seront à l'heure qu'ils
seront plus sécurisé d'avoir le maintien
aussi d'un maillage territorial qui est
important c'est ça qui intéresse à mon
avis les français beaucoup plus de ce
que de savoir quels ou quel statut sera
préservée selon le porte parole la
république en marche que gabriel attal a
eu un mot dont on a beaucoup parlé c'est
la gréviculture est-ce que vous
reprendriez vous un berger ce terme à
votre compte
oui je le reprendrais pas ce que c'est
vrai que on peut s'étonner quand même
que dans notre pays
souvent avant même que des négociations
aient lieu avant même que des
concertations et lieu on est des
syndicats qui préfère être dans des
stratégies de mise en place de grève
c'est ça qu'il a voulu dire
et c'est ça qui est en effet un peu
étonnant d'abord négocié ont conser ton
débat et quand on a des points de
désaccord alors la grève c'est l'ultime
recours
mais c'est pas le 1er des roms alors on
a entendu beaucoup et loire philippe ans
sur le sujet aussi la ministre elisabeth
bornes des députés la majorité actifs
dont vous faites partie mais on a
l'impression qu'il manque quand même des
poids lourds 1 pour défendre pour
défendre cette réforme est ce que par
exemple emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer
sur le sur le sujet cela n'est le mans
je fais rarement d'injonction au
président de la région savait pas moi
qui lui dictait s'il doit parler ou pas
je pense que vous êtes un peu sévère
quand vous dites qu'il ya pas deux poids
lourds entendu il est en charge des
transports l'a pas entendu il ya
énormément en tant que ministre des
transports qui lui est borné qui s'est
exprimé et je pense que c'est légitime
que ce soit elle qui porte ce dossier en
plus elle connaît quand même
particulièrement bien justement la
nécessité de la question de la
modernisation de la sncf le premier
ministre lui même s'est exprimé à
l'assemblée nationale que ce soit jean
baptiste djebbari qui les rapporteurs du
texte ou loriana rossi pareil alors
peut-être que vous les connaissez pas
encore assez je vous invite à les
inviter les invités encore plus les
progressions dans le monde à voter sur
la question et manuel macro est ce que
vous pensez parce que c'est une question
qui commence à se poser est ce que le
président doit justement prendre la
parole lors d'un jt lors d'une
allocution pour justement faire la
pédagogie comme l'a fait edouard
philippe cette semaine c'est le
président qui décidera ce c'est légitime
nécessaire ou pas ces peaux très
honnêtement pas à moi de le dire et pas
à moi de le lui dire je pense que ce qui
est important c'est d'arriver toujours à
replacer la cohérence des réformes qu'on
est en train de mener s'il n'y a pas de
réforme isolé pourquoi on fait une
ouverture à la concurrence air expliqué
que cette réforme est une réforme qui
est un processus qui vient de loin mais
de la même manière aussi expliquer
toutes les réformes qui vont arriver
parfois on nous dit vous faites trop de
réformes
mais dans le même temps on reprochait
souvent gouvernement précédent de
troupes attendre pour mener des réformes
dans tout le monde savait qu'elle était
nécessaire mais par exemple cette
semaine vous avez été amené
on l'a dit à défendre la réforme la sncf
la loi universités la loi immigration la
réforme constitutionnelle et au milieu
de toutes ces réformes quand même très
lourde
on en oublie presque dvd lois qui sont
aussi importants que l'oat pacte qui est
porté par bruno le maire la loi élan sur
le logement social qui a été annoncé
est ce que l'opinion arrive à digérer et
à voir le fils
au milieu de cet amoncellement de
réformes le fils c'est un enjeu de
transformation du pays donc quand vous
voulez transformer le pays vous pouvez
pas juste faire une réforme tous les six
mois
parce qu'on doit ouvrir tous les
chantiers du grossiste inaperçu et ses
réformes elles se complètent
quand jean michel blanquer refait la
réforme du baccalauréat et du lycée mais
il faut qu'ils aient un corollaire par
exemple sur la question de
l'apprentissage quand muriel pénicaud au
début du mandat fait la réforme du code
du travail by a un corollaire c'est la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
donc toutes ces réformes là elles ont du
sens ensemble et c'est pour ça qu'on les
conduit tout ensemble dans le même temps
merci merci' robert g merci à vous jim
merci oriane pour ce tour de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]